Bohemian Rhapsody will rock you — or at
least Rami Malek's performance in the film
will.
20th Century Fox screened Bohemian Rhapsody,
the musical drama biopic centered on the legendary
rock band Queen and it's even more iconic
frontman, Freddie Mercury, for press and critics
on Sunday, October 7th in Los Angeles.
Those in attendance have since shared online
their first reactions to the film.
The verdict?
Bohemian Rhapsody is largely enjoyable, if
not pretty cookie-cutter as far as biopics
go.
And while IndieWire's Anne Thompson expects
the film to "get mixed reviews," it appears
everyone agrees that Malek's turn as Freddie
Mercury is a dazzling sight to behold.
Many - even Kyle Buchanan of The New York
Times, who called the film a "glorified Wikipedia
entry" - have praised Malek's performance
as being out-of-this-world incredible.
In fact, they're already placing bets on Malek
receiving an Oscar nomination for Best Actor
for his work.
Us Weekly film critic Mara Reinstein tweeted,
"How do you turn an OK movie into a good one?
Five words: Rami Malek as Freddie Mercury.
#BohemianRhapsody."
Jenna Busch, the founder and editor in chief
of Legion of Leia, was also completely swept
away, tweeting,
"Absolutely beyond blown away by [Bohemian
Rhapsody]!
Rami Malek is phenomenal.
Gorgeous story, amazing concert movie…
I don't have enough words!"
More unabashed praise came from film critic
Scott Mantz, who exclaimed,
"HOLY HELL!!
[Bohemian Rhapsody] is ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC!!
A rousing emotional cinematic champion that
will rock you!
[Rami Malek] is magnificent!
It's great FUN & it will ROCK YOU!!
A Star Is Born, you've been served!!"
In the eyes of many critics, Malek went above
and beyond in his interpretation of Mercury.
"You don't want to mimic Freddy.
You want to be able to understand why he did
what he did."
Playing a real-life figure is never an easy
task for actors - no matter how much they
look like the people they portray.
For Malek, stepping into Mercury's shoes meant
more than just putting on an accent, rocking
eccentric costumes, and wearing false teeth
that gave him Mercury's famous overbite.
"You can pop em in and pop em out, but I chose
to keep them in for the majority of the shoot...Really,
even at lunch...No."
According to Entertainment Weekly, Malek practiced
singing Queen songs every night while wearing
the fake chompers before Fox even greenlit
Bohemian Rhapsody, and pored over Mercury's
past interviews and performances.
The actor even took a trip to London - financed
entirely out of pocket before Bohemian Rhapsody
had even received funding - to conduct research.
Malek met with Queen drummer Roger Taylor
and lead guitarist Brian May, dug into biographies,
and watched old footage of Mercury.
Additionally, Malek worked with movement coach
Polly Bennett to capture Mercury's unique
physicality, and collaborated with choreographers
ahead of filming to ensure he was as prepared
as he could be.
Speaking to Vanity Fair, Malek shared that
Bennett would have him, quote, "do ludicrous
things like ski across the room," in efforts
to mimic Mercury's signature on-stage theatrics.
Malek essentially studied every little thing
Mercury did.
He explained,
“I watched the way his lips moved while
he was singing, and everything that’s happening
in his throat and his vocal cords.”
Sounds like all that hard work paid off.
Once Fox lifts the review embargo a few days
ahead of the film's release, some opinions
about Bohemian Rhapsody are sure to change.
For now, though, the initial responses are
promising.
Decide for yourself whether Bohemian Rhapsody
is a killer queen or a just a bunch of radio
ga-ga when the movie debuts on November 2nd.
"Alright!"